you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum uh Ryan Taz your hair
looks nice today thank you yeah that's
nice do you uh put product in your hair
I don't I do I do you do well your hair
looks up
sorry it looks all right yeah
thanks it's sticking up I know sometimes
I didn't want you to put the headphones
on it's all yeah somehow your hair is
perfect with headphones
that's what I'm going for yeah well you
headphones
headphones by L'Oreal that's right
headphones by the way out
um
great uh episode today if you haven't
seen Wet Hot American Summer if you
haven't seen role models and a slew of
so many projects super talented guy like
Fleetwood Mac he goes his own way
um he's just David Wayne is uh he's a
great guy I've jammed with him at his
house
he's he's a kid like me in a lot of ways
he just uh you know he's obviously
responsible has kids
does this thing but there's just a
youthful feel to him and I like that he
was easy to talk to and we've known each
other since 1998.
but we were never really close or
anything but we're always like oh I like
him I hope he likes me
um
and it was really great to have him um
just before we get started if you guys
will if you're new if you're David Wayne
fans uh listen to the podcast just for
him hopefully you'll listen to more
episodes if you like this and I hope you
do
um our handles are Ryan at inside of you
pod on Twitter at inside of your podcast
on Instagram and Facebook that's right
you can watch on YouTube uh write a
review it really helps the podcast and
if you want to join patreon to help
support the podcast we need you without
my patrons I couldn't do the show
patreon.com talkfill there's top tiers I
read their names at the end of every
episode I send boxes of merch that I
pack and I sign little notes to each
person and they become like a family
also you can go to the inside you online
store and get awesome stuff like lexmus
scripts signed by me and inside of you
mugs and tumblers and small the lunch
boxes and the ship Keys signed by me
from Smallville and many other great
things uh you can also go to my other
podcast talk thepodcast.com and get tons
of cool merch and original art and all
that stuff also my band is out there if
you want to support the band sunspin two
words Sun spin go to sunspin.com you can
zoom with me you could buy merch and you
can listen to our new album never as
what it is anywhere you stream so I hope
you'll give it a chance listen to what
are we here for it's the theme song to
talk though that will give you an idea
of what we're going for and trying to
build an audience for that so if you
want to do that that's great I'm asking
a lot of you uh we're going to a lot
we're going to Chicago this weekend uh
Tom Welling and I we're going to be
doing pictures and autographs and hugs
and a lot of energy grab a Red Bull
you'll need
and um what else can I say
what else can you say
I think that's really it
did I miss anything
no I don't think so I hope you're having
a great week
um you know uh
I I have a you know I had an incredible
weekend last weekend
um can't really talk about it but good
stuff and a lot of stuff in the works so
I'm hoping you know being more more
creative trying to get projects going
along and uh
you know keeping the uh keeping the
podcast alive and uh again talk Ville is
our new podcast on the side we watch
every episode of Smallville Ryan for the
first time ever me mostly for the first
time and we review it and that's Taco
Bell podcast even ones that you're in
the entirety of that are based around
you
that's got to be fun yeah sometimes it's
fun sometimes I'm annoyed with myself
I'm like ah you did that because you're
Hamming it up
whatever uh I hope you enjoy the podcast
let's get let's just do it let's just
dive in let's uh get inside of David
Wayne it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
and what station is this on
wkdq 99.5 Fm w a i n
David Wayne all day long
uh boy is it a treat to have you here I
I listen I'm I'm excited about this are
those real those Muppets up up there uh
well they don't they're not alive but
that but are they I mean you know
there's obviously a big difference
between a toy and an actual you mean the
original or one that might have been
used no no I had those made there was
this woman in Australia that I met at a
convention and she had these puppets and
I was like wow can you make me a
Princess Leia could you make me a Hello
bury the lead this guy's been to
Australia hello all right why didn't we
start with that I've really done it I've
made a name for myself oh my god
um first of all explain when you got out
of your car I noticed there was an a
Rubik's Cube yeah that's what's that
about well a lot of things I do are like
I'm 11 years old because there's a part
of me that just is and so in my mid-40s
I'm now in my mid 50s oh my gosh are you
really well I'm 53. well that's not
quite mid don't go there yet okay I'm
not gonna go there I'm on the right side
of 55. yeah let's say that I like that
um sometime in my mid 40s I picked up
that Rubik's Cube and I'm like [__] it I
gotta learn this for the first time and
I stopped my life and got really good at
it for a second how long did it take you
to to actually do it the first time you
did it well I followed and anyone can
solve a Rubik's Cube in 10 minutes if
you follow the instructions it's not
that complicated to do the challenge is
how fast you can do it and my son for
example can do it in under 20 seconds
um what I can do it in about 50 seconds
that that seems astonishing to me it is
astonishing it's a great it's learning
the Rubik's Cube for me was a wonderful
uh
expression of how you can learn
something that seems impossible and day
by day time by time you get a tiny bit
better at it and that thing that seemed
like a magic trick or impossible at
first it's like oh now I can do it I've
never done it I always I have one I just
think it's impossible I I you know what
I think it's weird because as we've
gotten into this before gotten into this
about like I never thought it was very
smart I never thought and I I just I
never did either but I yeah that's still
how I feel that little boy in me stuff
oh you can't do no Rubik's Cube you're
not someone else so don't even go there
right that's for smart people Rubik's
Cubes but you're saying I could do it
probably you really could it's just like
anything it's you learn it and it's like
it's a way you can learn it and it's
it's kind of fun I have to say it's a
fun adult activity to learn how to
actually properly solve a Rubik's Cube
did you hear that guys you could
actually do in a Rubik's Cube I think we
should try that
I think we should yeah you just have to
decide to take a little time and not
just try to jump to the end like how
much time are we talking I don't know I
mean taking an hour or two here and
there for a few weeks
you're probably good at those Cracker
Barrel games too what I would do though
is I would get obsessed then I would
like sit and do it for hours because I
just was like I gotta get this I gotta I
gotta nail this and of course anything
in the world that you really want to
learn there's there's YouTube
true tutorials you also brought cards
with you well the magic tricks thing has
been always my whole life since I'm born
you do magic tricks yeah
well could you do one today I mean we'll
see we'll see we'll see how it goes like
you brought them just I just have them
always
that's just you know that's just who you
are it's just part of me
um first of all I uh I text your good
friends Joe the truglio and Ken Marina
my name is David Wayne by the way yeah
just to start there we do that in the
beginning okay before you even come do
an intro all right so they're gonna know
all about this stuff great here I am and
we're gonna get into it did you you know
I've done that before where I'm on a
podcast and they never talk about who I
am or what I've done or anything I'm
like No One's Gonna know who the [__]
yeah unless they happen to know your by
voice and by fandom which is true for
many some some some people yeah you have
a lot of fans I do have some I would say
I I'm one of those people that has a
very very small but devoted uh football
fans yeah which is great Joe both of
these are sort of non-sequiturs to me I
don't I don't know what these mean Joe
the triple you said ask about Leonard
Gaines he was a New York University
Professor who taught an African-American
music class that you took yes uh he was
great
um this guy Joe and I took an African
American music class at NYU and this guy
just had a very funny way of being
one of the things that we always
remember is he somebody asked him you
know he was a former trumpet player and
they said well do you ever play now
the normal question you'd say the
professor do you ever play trumpet
yourself now and he's like no I I just
don't do it anymore if I if I did it I
would still be doing it but I just don't
do it anymore
yeah I'm like okay
and the other thing I always remember
was he would say uh
you know there was the country blues and
there was the City Blues and then there
was blind lemon Jefferson and the thing
about blind lemon Jefferson is no one
can outblind lemon Jefferson blind lemon
Jefferson and no one can out Fletcher
Henderson Fletcher Henderson and you
just had a very funny
a teacher you'll never forget there are
very few teachers like that wouldn't you
say that sort of stick in your memory oh
my God very very few I had one that was
uh uh it was a sound class sound design
college and I just remember goes the
first thing he said that's all I
remember is what is sound sound
is vibrating air sound is the thing I
like to hear coming out of my mouth
that's why I remember Dr wozlowski
wadalowski or something like that and
okay Ken Marino another member of the
state yes Joe latrulia was you guys went
to NYU together we did Joe uh Ken says
uh something about Kaja taking fits if
you had any conjure taking fits lately
so both of those are just references to
like things that I don't show up uh
when I so dumb when I was like
eight in in elementary school some weird
old man came and told us funny stories
like some like some guy came in I don't
know and he was like have you ever heard
about couch taking fits you know it's
like my
my uncle would
take the Cod and it's like how much Cod
you've taken and he had cops taking fits
I don't even know what it was but then I
I would just do my own telephone game of
telling that same story I I propose
nothing in the middle of like a writer
session sometimes and people be like
what the [__] are you talking about and
uh so
um it was just sort of a very weird
random words that would come out of my
mouth and that Ken Marino remembered
that's sort of I feel like that you guys
have a lot of those inside things as
well these weird little things that you
do the bizarre thing is you know we're
all in our early 50s and yes yes I still
work together very often with different
members of the state who were these guys
we met when we were 18 years old and so
there's many decades of weird random
shorthand or inside little references
and so we might be in a meeting about
something with me and Ken Marino and X
and Y and Z and I'll make a little weird
I'll be like in the middle of a sentence
I'll be cut
and it's just to make Ken laugh and
everyone else is like what are you
talking about so you just do it to make
that person I think I do that with my
friends
I'll do that yeah I think everybody does
it but that's nice uh look dude you've
done so many things and you have a very
you have a brand David Wayne has a brand
you're a brand dude
um that's original That's Unique that no
one very few people have a brand a lot
of people can make movies and TV and
it's sort of linear although these days
it's all about the brand isn't it
everybody talks about the brand
but Wet Hot American Summer Role Models
wonderlust they came together with an
American Summer the series uh yeah I
mean all these things the the sort of
your sense of humor the what you find
funny it's just a quirky different take
on Comedy it's like your own like you
said Niche kind of thing your brand yeah
and that started you'd say that it
started a young age where you always
sort of
just going for a laugh trying to make
what was it like growing up as a Wayne I
definitely was the class clown of my
family
um I would entertain my family uh I was
the youngest by far of I'm three much
older sisters and my parents and and I
would just do schtick and during dinner
and you know
um but I think that my
slightly off kilter what kind of jokes I
would make were encouraged by people
around me and and and I got you know
confidence in that somehow and I really
loved Steve Martin and I loved Woody
Allen and sort of their weirder
absurdist makes sense my Notions and
um then I was just had this incredibly
lucky
uh happenstance of meeting a bunch of
like-minded people right when I got to
NYU and finding that my you know sense
of humor is not identical to theirs but
it was complementary enough that we
really all encouraged each other and
learned from each other instead of from
some higher Mentor or teacher or book or
something we really we really mostly
taught each other everything
and so I guess I emerged and also just
had the lucky uh chance to have it have
the opportunity to make things like wet
Hot American Summer where end State and
all those early things where we were
allowed to do this these projects the
way we wanted to and and and follow
these weird
um
humorous tangents that
maybe in a in a more normal business
situation they'd be like you can't do
that cut that out you know we're
the way I used to talk about it was like
the the thing you joke about at the
dinner table
but then you're like we're not really
going to do that in the thing you know
and be like no let's do that in the
thing and so that that kind of is but it
was none of this was ever really like
that conscious we're just like we're
doing what's funny and I always think
about when we were doing our show Stella
on Comedy Central
um I saw Stella live sure yeah so
Stella's live and I just I remember it
was so fun if you guys get a chance and
you sell the DVDs that's the only way
you could wait you could find them yeah
well they sold out they sold out of the
Stella shorts yeah but the original
Stella shorts you can still see them
online though but uh that we had we
found a bunch of old DVDs of it and sold
them and they sold I still quoted
seconds I still quote this one thing
where I went to this show and look it's
it's a little toilet humor but it's so
funny there's this one sketch where uh
the family is having dinner and the moms
you know Mom just is freaking out and
she farts on stage I don't know if you
remember this you probably don't and and
somebody go and she storms out of the
room then she starts puking and then
somebody says everything's fine guys the
family we're doing fine and somebody
goes fine Mom just barfed and founded oh
right right how are we fine or something
that was the state was that the state
yeah that was uh really funny and he's
like and she barfed and she ferreted
she's ferreted just weird pronunciation
yeah that was I remember that that was I
think a Showalter piece yeah but that's
but that's sort of all your sense of
humor yeah do ridiculous things like
that totally in the state now but I
remember I was going to just say we were
doing that show Stella on Comedy Central
and in retrospect I can acknowledge that
was a very weird show but at the time we
were like we're just doing a funny show
like it's just funny like a sitcom like
funny like friends you know it didn't
occur to us that it was
that off to the left as as and then when
it went on the air the response was
either like this is terrible I hate it
or this is the most bizarre you know why
would anyone it's no surprise that it
wouldn't get picked up for another
season but um we're just doing what we
do and so but is it is it hard when
you're doing something that you find
funny that you know is different that
you don't get picked up for another
season or whatever like the state right
you did it like 25 episodes we did we
ended up doing yeah it was sort of Four
Seasons worth over but they were very
tiny Seasons yeah right but did you did
you ever feel at some and I want to get
back to your childhood and that stuff
but like did you ever feel at some point
in your life you're like well maybe I
should go more mainstream comedy because
maybe that's what they want and try
almost fighting yourself in your
instinct all the time of course and you
still do that well and I'd say I do it
even more now because now I have bills
to pay and I have kids and you know and
it the the whims of the marketplace for
me go up and down all the time of course
it's never been a consistent ride ever
you know it's always been like slow
periods and then things go better and
but uh
for the most part mostly throughout my
career whenever I've talked to any of
the powers that be whether it's rep reps
or producer Studios they're always like
oh we're a big fan of what you do but we
can't do that here you know like and so
it's always been that push-pull of like
do we do something more mainstream or
more down the middle you know do you
like any down the middle I love down the
middle I mean I mean depending on how
you define it but
the most mainstream thing I ever did was
with this Role Models movie yeah and I
love it I loved every second of it and
and that was us sort of layering in our
point of view in a much very
straightforward vessel and I thought
that was a wonderful experience and I
wanted to do that type of thing again
um and also I love like one of my
favorite movies of all time is like Miss
Congeniality like I no joke like amazing
I love love love straightforward stuff
too and and I mostly
consume as a uh as a TV Watcher or a
movie Watcher non-comedic stuff in the
first place you know I I
think of it left like being at work and
so on my free time I watched Breaking
Bad you know right did you ever feel
like sort of compelled like in your
later years after you kind of created
Wet Hot American Summer and all these
different things in the state and did
you ever feel like compelled to be weird
or quirky or off just so you almost like
you couldn't really truly be you you're
trying to be someone else as growing up
does that make sense so yes it makes
total sense a great question and the
answer is not really it's usually the
opposite it's usually I'm trying to do
or or I'm in a place where I'm assigned
to do something and I'm naturally
looking to push it weirder and I have to
stop that because it's not what we're
doing you know whether I'm directing a
regular TV show or something you know
and uh we're or we're struggling with a
script moment I'm like well you know if
we were doing this like in a vacuum I
would say let's have him you know turn
around and jump in a pool of water here
or something weird and and I'm like I
know we can't do that so let's you know
that always comes to you let's do the
harder way right
um but no I luckily I don't think the
the demand for my brand is so uh
actually uh existent that people are
like you've got to be weird and I feel
pressure to be right you know in any way
more
off than I am and I'm not that off I'm
just like a dude yeah you are dude but
do you ever think like some people might
think I guess Studios would think oh
it's a risk because it's that certain
brand and we don't know if that's gonna
either hit or not it's too much of a
risk we want something more mainstream
well I feel like I've
consistently my whole career not gotten
work because people are like oh he can
only do that like his his stuff is funny
but it's too weird for us you know and
and you're like no I can do the others I
did Role Models I do I've used exactly
and also I can I've I've done the range
of things over time and uh you know I
can handle you know as a director had
sometimes been frustrated because I've
I've done such a wide variety of styles
and levels and and uh media and
um as you said the brand can have
um a double edge to it and people like
oh he's the guy who just does like
really goofy dumb things and so we have
this thing that we have a real feeling
about in the matters test so there's no
way he could handle that yeah I'm like
yeah do you just feel like you have to
fight more these days for something
you're passionate about or do you and
you you still obviously write your own
stuff
yes I do I I've always generated my own
um but I also do feel like yeah I think
just the natural uh progression and
getting older and I'm not in the I'm not
in that I'm not young anymore and I'm a
middle-aged white guy in Hollywood and I
I definitely have to
I feel like I have to work harder to get
heard and that's fine but you know
another cool thing is you think you
think looking at your resume and looking
at the people who follow you looking at
the people who want to be in your movies
who are consistently cast in your movies
like The Paul rudds and all these other
names that you see these big names they
obviously love you and love your mind
and want to work with you yeah so that
should excite Studios yeah
it sometimes does yeah it also is like
you know as you know as we all know
writing something coming up with
something is starting from scratch every
time and you're Reinventing the wheel
every time so
you know it's just a question of like
a lot of times if I have a thing which
and I've got all these things going
right now for example that I'm
developing and hopefully gonna start
shooting and
but you have to start from scratch every
time so you're like okay what's another
idea that feels real to me that feels
true that is funny and that could sell
and then you're just starting from a
blank page every time so it's it's never
easy how many how many projects do you
have just in what you're working on
right now
I kind of at the moment it's in
different phases I have I guess like
maybe three features and maybe like five
TV things
but that's I think that's a lot of
things but it's too it's a it's at it's
a combination for me honestly of both
too much and not enough like because the
I don't like to be spread thin I'm not
happy when I'm working on even more than
one project I'm most happy when I'm
fully and without invested and I'm in
prep or shooting or posts where I'm like
really really deeply and I can't even
think about anything else that's when
I'm happiest at my work yeah um but in a
phase where you're developing pitching
writing you know and you sort of have to
juggle things because you just don't
know what's going to take flight that's
less fun for me
um but necessary
but I think and you always hear this
they always say like you could be like I
love this right I've done this before
where I I wrote something and I'm like
this has to sell this is it this is
genius and that's all I'm focused on but
if that doesn't sell right which most of
the time it doesn't right what else do I
have going on so that's why you have to
have a lot of things like you have going
so that when the one hits hopefully boom
I'm going to that right now yeah it's
it's that balance has been a constant
question or challenge for me because
there's also that fantasy I have of I
think of an idea I spend every ounce of
me to get that thing done get it done
put it out there take a break and then
do that again like that would be my
fantasy life if I could pull that off
but I've never been realistically as you
said you have to have a million irons in
the fire because you know they're all
gonna yeah everything's half the ninety
percent of things aren't not going to
come to fruition so it's it's an
interesting challenge it is
do you you know a lot of times on this
podcast we talk to a lot of
professionals a lot of actors and you
know celebrities whatever about you know
how they deal with things how they deal
with work with life the balance some
people get anxiety some people get
depression I get both yeah you know uh
has there been a lot I mean look you're
comedian you're you're someone who puts
it all out there there's got to be hey
do you always have to be doing something
and if you're not are you depressed do
you get depressed or do you get anxiety
how does that I would say
uh I I don't know that I get into what
you could call clinical depression or
anxiety too much
um but I definitely
feel like I need to stay busy that's
certain something that gets me you know
I when I wake up and I'm like not
exactly sure what I'm supposed to do
that day I that's a bad thing like I
really try to have projects in front of
me and I've managing my time and
attention has been in a
number one focus and area of anxiety for
me for my entire career you know and
trying to understand the best way to
spend my time and
you know we all just realize the things
like if I have to edit something for
whatever reason that's easy and fun for
me and I can sit there for 12 hours
without even going to the bathroom if I
have to write something it's the
opposite you know I'll go for one minute
and then I get distracted and like let
me go you know play a game or whatever
and and
um
if it's a music thing which is only a
hobby for me but that's something that's
easy for me to focus on it just depends
on where
what I'm doing but yes I do we all I go
through all those things we we all do
what about being on Set uh are you sort
of an anxious perfectionist God I don't
want to run out of time I've got to do
this at the end of the day you're just
exhausted mentally and physically I'm in
a pretty good place on set I think I
learned early on that to be a good
director you just sort of you you just
arrive into a Zone and then you have a
plan and you
have your brain firing all day and I I
really love that and I don't I don't get
stressed out on set I I really love wow
I feel in the zone when I'm directing
but do you ever feel like uh a problem
occurs and you don't know how to solve
it and you're the cast is looking at you
and you just oh I'm a little [__] I'm
out of my and does it ever get like
amped up I have I have found over time
that I get if I'm if a problem appear
you know like the the wind blows over
the set now what are we gonna do I know
that those things are going to happen
and I just get very Zen about it I'm
like all right let's figure out how
we're gonna solve that and because I
think I went through such a trial by
fire on my very first thing Wet Hot
American Summer where it poured rain
every single day almost every day when
you're filming that right daylight
exterior short low budget shoot supposed
to be a nice day it all takes place in
one sunny day and pouring pouring rain
all day and so it was the ultimate daily
like what the [__] are we gonna do
situation and I learned then it's like
to let go of what's out of your control
focus on what you what Solutions might
be in front of you and just do it and
and somehow on set with that structure I
thrive you know where you don't have to
think about what am I going to do today
you know you've got you've got to get up
and do it and so
the I I don't I don't think I would do
well to be like someone who's always in
production and so if I was working on a
camera crew or something where every day
of my life I've that I work that I have
to do that I think I would burn out but
I really love the thing I love the most
about my life and my work is that it
changes all the time sometimes you're
really mellow and you're working with
one person in a room by yourself or
sometimes you're with a small crew doing
something and or you're on set being the
general of an army of a hundred have you
ever had a difficult time with an actor
where you're just like I do not get
along with this guy is giving me a hard
time this is difficult of course and
what do you do
well I think
you know first of all you look around
you're like it's not me right
I'm not the [__] here and then you
just try to it's just same it's actually
the same thing as what we're saying like
you're just like okay so here's the
problem what are the solutions what are
what are the tactics we can use and
you'll be like okay in this case you
know do we do we have to fire the person
do we or do we just have to fire anyone
before oh yeah sure you have
um yeah I'm uh if you're talking about
like an actor during a shoot yeah there
was one
uh situation I was involved in so more
indirectly where the actor was being
inappropriate you know a couple times
couple that where somebody was being
inappropriate were just like that has to
be the line sorry and you have to and we
had to let fire the mid shoot someone
you knew someone you liked at first or
someone you just said no not really
someone I didn't know well but somebody
like that the one that I'm thinking of
right now we were doing a TV show and an
actor came to do a relatively small part
and but was like uh being super
inappropriate with women on set and and
we all talked and very quickly we're
like we just got it cut bait right here
you know right and uh
but you know normally if an actor is
difficult you're not going to fire them
but you're going to try to just you know
talk to them and say hey you know what
you're doing is affecting everyone else
and can you not do that you know or
don't just hang out in your trailer why
would I do that David why would I do
that right well I mean I know you're
that guy you're the one difficult I've
never never
um I always do what they say
but it's just you know I don't think
film making is different than any other
workplace challenge you know somebody's
doing something difficult you gotta deal
with them and figure it out and try to
be understanding but also guys on the
prize of what we're all trying to get
done
[Music]
asked is brought to you by Dove men plus
care guys do you get distracted during
the day thinking about your underarm
sweating or itching or emitting an odor
oh do those thoughts keep you from
showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72-hour sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold
what did you go to NYU for I I was into
NYU film school for film school and I
concentrated I I guess I used to say at
a concentration in children's TV but I
really I took a couple classes in
children's TV
but uh basically I went to film school
and then and so I mean you've told the
story but in a nutshell who did you bump
into first was it Showalter
or Merino
met me and Todd hollaback and Ken Marino
were um were the in a class ahead we so
we were there as freshmen and Ken Moreno
I met the first day of school because I
was assigned to be roommates with
somebody he grew up with in Long Island
and so my myself and Craig wedron were
living with this guy and Ken Marino
knocked on our door and he was like this
Italian guy from Long Island they were
like I love Camp no but we were we loved
him from moment one so we all hang out
and Todd hollaback basically Mo Willems
who is now the biggest children's book
author on Earth had started he was one
ahead of us and had started an improv
group and a sketch group at NYU and I
joined that and
um
then uh there was a new group that Todd
hollaback Todd hollaback was in our
group and he decided we decided that we
didn't want to let new freshmen into our
group so Todd decided instead to start
like a B team at JV Squad and he left to
start a new group and that was like an
open meeting anyone who wants to be part
of this new sketch comedy group uh that
was like an offshoot of our main group
the steriliac
um could do it and then that became the
state that was the group that you know
and ever the main people from the state
Michael Showalter and Carrie Kenny and
Tomlin they all just showed up there and
uh that became the that was like the
Freshman B Team group and then when it
became clear to me and pretty much
everyone that that group was what was
really special
um our main senior group sort of
dissolved and I begged to be part of
this the new really yeah well there are
a lot of people that got were there at
first but they kind of were weeded out
because they they just weren't funny
there were some yeah but it was shocking
how much of the main Core group was
still the same you know the state never
officially disbanded we're still a group
it's 11 of us and this is now 30 plus
years later and and it's the same core
do you think you'll ever get together
again to do something yeah we do we talk
about it actually quite regularly and
we've we've done we have done we have
reunited with and written new material
for certain live shows we've done uh
over the years and you know we're all
still friends and we all still recognize
how special it was and we are always
talking about Brewing something I see
how supportive you are I was at Joe the
truglio's screening for his film his
horror movie late movie great and you
were there supporting and Michael Jan
was there Camarino was there and it was
nice to see after all these years you
guys still support each other I mean not
just that we went over to his house when
he was editing and we like helped gave
him notes notes like we always it's
really great to have uh you know a core
of people that you have each other's
backs even though we've all obviously
gone in various different directions and
pursued different Avenues and worked
with different people but you have sort
of like a family that you came from and
it's really nice do you try to cast
those guys or your close friends it
seems like you do obviously in in just
about everything you do if you can if
it's right yeah I mean I have over the
years
um done that did they ever get mad when
you're like what happened to my audition
what about me yeah totally do they ever
say anything to you sure I mean you know
that it's it's a double-edged sword like
we in our movie The 10 we tried to cast
every single person in the state and
even Ken wrote that yeah me and Kenya
and we did uh give everybody a part but
you know it's like sometimes you know
when you try to make it a thing and then
it's like it it it's you know how
casting is you never know
it's it's hard when you have to have a
mandate about casting yeah um no matter
what and but uh it has definitely been a
thing where we try to bring in
or or we end up bringing it a lot of
times
for example in our movie Wanderlust we
had this part
um of this guy who's a naked guy running
around the this commune and we
auditioned all sorts of different actors
who were great and like different types
and really funny and did you audition
them naked some of them did What Would
un asked kind and solicited they fully
take their clothes off saw their penis
it was crazy did you love it I mean I
mean love it as in like like that they
took the risk not that you love their
dogs I love the memory that that
happened but no I was not loving that I
would rather than not do that I'm like
you we can if we get to there we'll look
at you yeah we don't have to do that
right now
um any big ones by the way yeah there
were some big dogs there were some big
ones yeah I bet they stretched it and
put warm water on it I mean it's hard
for me to have any because I I have like
the biggest penis
I'm just sort of famous
but uh anyway the point about that was
that we at the end of the day as we were
trying to figure out how to who's gonna
really nail this we were just like oh
let's just get Joe and then like Joe
Ocho came in and was like the greatest
thing you know like sometimes
for me the luckiest thing about me is
for my taste these are some of the
funniest people I've ever met and never
will meet and like you know
it it just happens that we all knew each
other in college so great why not when
you were doing the state in your mind
you recall saying this guy is going to
be a star were there anybody in the
state or where did you just saying
everybody here is going to be but who
was the guy or the girl that you were
like they are going to make it in
Hollywood well as I mentioned I wasn't
in the group originally so I got to see
their first show which was like
literally freshman at NYU in a little
black box theater doing some skits that
they wrote but I was like holy [__] and
when I think I I think Michael Black
stood out to me first I was like this
guy is so funny oh my God so funny but
then very quickly I I clocked them all
Michael show out there and Carrie Kenny
I was just like Jesus these guys are
really funny you know you know going
back to like putting your friends in
things I I gotta give it to you I mean
there's a lot of people out here when
they make it they don't bring people
along with them they don't it
I made a little movie for eight hundred
thousand dollars shot in Indiana God
bless you didn't get a uh tax break
nothing and I tried to put my friends in
the movie as many as I could yeah
because it was like I I just feel better
I have more fun when my friends were
around and they're certainly capable so
when I see you and I see your movies and
you're putting all your friends in eat
my friend Matt Ballard you always throw
them at a bone greatest guy in the world
I've known Madison's College we did
theater together yeah we lived together
in New York and I love that about you I
always say David Wayne is one of those
guys
who does the right thing well but who
doesn't want to be among friends when
you're working what a great thing you
know yeah and I just think it's it makes
it fun and exciting and you know it's
everything has its pros and cons but
it's just it's yeah it's always nice to
to
if you're in a position no matter what
you do for a living if you're in a
position to help people you care about
why wouldn't you try you know that's
certainly how I feel
um that's crazy and now listen when I
coughed before just a little tips from
someone who's been around the block just
the tip uh when you're going through
later and you're playing down the tape
you just edit that take a little razor
to that one part and you cut I learned
this in college at NYU in 1990 and then
you raise her out the other side and
then you just tape it together very
carefully with a piece of white tape and
then the cough is gone is that what you
have to do now all that worked just for
that I mean now maybe it's digital who
knows
yeah these days I mean if a friend of
mine wants to set me up on a home
computer what the what the hell am I
gonna do with a home computer but I
guess I don't know home computers
yeah apparently he he doesn't have to
anymore
um write down his recipes he can just
keep them all in the computer so okay I
guess keep going just keep going hold on
taking a picture everyone has it
everyone wants to have a website now
like apparently you know it's like
everyone's get your own web even
Microsoft has their own website now
apparently
what year are we in what year is this
can you call Paul Rudd right now if you
want it and he'd answer
it's possible
yeah he's that good a friend would you
say he's the top 10 friends of in your
life
um yeah maybe in in terms of
uh the whole of my life he's up there
talk about a guy talk about um
uh loyalty
did you just meet him but you met him
before white hot American or did he
audition
we I knew I sort of knew him through
Zach orth because Zach or Zach the best
I got the best Zach orth had been in the
boss Lerman Romeo and Juliet yes with
Paul uh in the late 90s and
basically Zach invited him to see this
weird little play that me and Michael
shelter and Julia Julia wrote called sex
AKA wieners and boobs and remember that
and uh he came and was just like oh my
God whatever you guys the Irish deck is
right out my alley and so we basically
at the time were trying to figure out
how to get wet Hot American Summer put
together and we said would you you know
attach her and he wasn't a name then not
no not really not really he had been in
200 Cigarettes and he had been in he was
in Clueless uh yes and he also had
played the Romantic lead in um object of
My Affection with Jennifer Aniston so he
was not in big name at all but he was
enough of a name for us to like say like
it would be value added to our project
if you would be part of it so you just
offered in the part so we offered him a
part and I didn't really know him or his
work that well quite honestly
um but I knew I liked what I had seen
and I was like that's great it would be
awesome if you were part of it and so
um yeah and then I didn't really really
get to know him until he came to set to
do Wet Hot American Summer were you
Blown Away by how good he was how funny
he was I have to admit I was less I was
like he's okay I really didn't get it
until I was in editing really I that and
and it was only then that I was like oh
this guy's
otherworldly you know and then since and
then since then and I was lucky enough
to I think make five movies in a row
with Paul and every [__] take every
time like you're just like this guy is
the magic like he's he's really quite
something you know what's amazing is
what you just said as a director you're
watching him on set and you're going
yeah whatever yeah and then you're
editing and you're finding out the
genius
it reminds me of that that show the
offer did you see the offer no it's the
making of um The Godfather and the
studio Robert Evans was like looking at
the Dale he didn't want Pacino he says
no this guy's no good Bob was a good
friend was he just to many people I'm
sure too many people sure but he watched
the dailies and he's like this this is
crap this is what is he doing and it
wasn't until later when they put it
together but they put the genius
together yeah so but how do you
how do you know that you don't know well
I mean everything yeah so many things
just come with experience and there's
just no substitute for understanding
that but yeah with Paul I don't know I
mean I think I was making my first movie
and I was thinking about a thousand
things and you know I just didn't really
clock how great he was and uh but in
post like I said you're just like
looking at them like oh my God this
guy's like working on a different level
and then over the years working very
closely with him and you know starring
in movies that we you know we're working
together writing together I just see how
his
you know and it seems so
he's not the kind of guy that talks
about his process that much or like is
very uh highfalutin about it at all and
I mean I have memories of working on
things where he's playing you know
Scrabble on his phone and until like
after we've said action I'm like put
your phone away it's time to start it's
like all right okay and then just boom
and he's in the like so in it and so
real and so funny
and also he'll give you in four takes
he'll give you four completely different
but all great and usable options for
this amazing you know it's it's a and it
really makes you appreciate you know as
me as someone who's done the fair amount
of acting but never really been great at
it and like understand like just the
appreciation for that art form is just
you know when you see someone who just
has that thing you know what are you
gonna do DiCaprio
has that he was doing What's Eating
Gilbert Grape yeah and they say that he
would just be in like ah mama you know
like but first he'd be like joking
farting and laughing and doing all these
things off stage and actually he's like
I don't know if you and he would get
into this character like that yeah
and that is
it's amazing and I think that a lot of
people have to do that I can't sit there
and stew in the part and just constantly
thinking of the heart I'm best when I'm
just talking to people joking around and
action and then I could jump into it if
I'm thinking about things too much it's
not going to be as good yeah when
everyone has a different way to get
there and they're all legitimate and
I've learned that too every actor has a
different process and that's great you
know and I've done some of my favorite
acting of myself when I'm directing at
the same time because I'm not it
prevents me from overthinking it right
and so if I'm thinking about everything
else and then it's just action then I'm
just like doing it yeah you're like the
Hitchcock I'm like you always
appearance yeah
the white male Hitchcock wait a minute
wasn't Hitchcock no in many ways yes
have you um
ever worked with actors who have an
intense method or way of working where
you just don't go to them go don't talk
who's one that's just an intense person
but amazing and you love working with
oh my God let me think
um
I mean like uh Maloney it's Chris
Maloney has a an intense presence on
sense you know and he'll he'll be very
thoughtful and he'll he'll he'll he does
that thing where you're talking to him
about like you're trying to answer a
question he has and he won't respond
back even with a look and you're just
like then just keep nattering off at the
mouth and and but you can tell he's just
thinking and and like processing and you
know everybody's got you know and he's
just really thinking it through and it's
like the dumbest scene about whatever
and he's like okay yeah
and then he puts it together and you're
like wow yeah oh I've been blowing my
mind but I I will say I've worked with I
can't I honestly can't remember names
but I've worked with some actors maybe
in smaller ways where they really get
enamored with like the method type work
and then and it's just [__] you know
and you're just like just come and do it
just shut up you know or like and it's
that famous to me it's that thing of
sometimes the reason why this character
would do it is because it's written down
in set on the sides and you were paid to
be here to do it so that's why that's
the reason she does have you ever dealt
with insecure actors who are you just
like
how do you deal with an insecure actor
someone who can't get it who's really in
their head you could tell they're
nervous that happens all the time and
sometimes you just have to be like okay
let's you know give me a second and then
go off the side and be like hey you got
this or whatever you know just it's like
a coach you know how to make them
comfortable yeah or I've tried I mean
the the being a director which one's so
fun is like sometimes you just have to
be like a cheerleader or a coach or a
therapist or a parent or you know or and
then sometimes you have to just learn to
let someone do their thing and complete
them completely alone and try trying to
say as little as possible it just
depends and it's fun I always remember
doing a scene in um
Wet Hot American Summer where
Janine Garofalo who really thrives on
just showing up and just
spouting off and improvising doing
whatever and not thinking about it as
much and Marguerite Moreau was one of
her first things and she really wanted
to rehearse and really get it right and
really like get the Beats all down and
we had two very separate ways of
processing and it was fun to try to
figure out you know how to make that
work and I would I ran the scene a lot
with Marguerite and like made sure she
felt comfortable and like there was
everything was covered
um but then left space for Janine to do
her thing but some people just don't
like to rehearse too much they don't
want to they'll go through the blocking
but they don't want to no they want to
feel it for the first time really when
they're rolling and that's got to be
difficult when another actor was like no
I want to rehearse it can be or or
sometimes an actor wants to do 20 takes
you know they want to like warm up in in
the actual shooting they're like I don't
really get going until you don't like
that do you well I personally would I
can't that I can't do I I don't have the
patience or the attention span or
usually ever the budget to to do that
you're like we gotta move yeah or I just
I also just feel like
it's really diminishing returns at a
certain point like you you know you
hopefully you've worked on the script
and you've worked on the rehearsing if
there's rehearsing but and then when the
camera's rolling and there's 100 people
there you gotta just sort of you got it
great let's keep going I don't see you
losing your [__] have you ever lost your
[__] on set where you're like God damn
it
it I mean in 30 years it's happened but
it's been very rare and it's not
terrible but I've I've had moments where
I've like raised my voice and been like
you know but right I would say compared
to most probably pretty minor it's
pretty amazing like wet Hot American
Summer the legs that it has I mean
you're shooting this movie in Rain no
sunlight it's your first movie first
feature this is it no budget yeah
a lot of great actors in this character
actors yeah
how many days it was 20 uh 29 total
including one day every shoot
remember but it was shooting on film
with one camera
so one camera you shot that with yeah
well you know most things were shot with
one camera at the time this is in the
year 2000 and so that just to keep that
in mind when people are going I shot a
movie in nine days it's like yeah but
it's one camera and you're rolling 35
millimeter so you're to reload and we
also had limited stock that was the
other thing you couldn't just shoot as
much as you want that was not at all an
option you know and when we would have a
day where we'd shoot a lot of film stock
the producer would be like dude can't
use so much film
it was like there's a lot of challenges
when yeah when you went home at night
after day one or day five or day eight
when you're lying in bed and you close
your eyes lying in the camp bunk that's
where you guys slept yeah
with other people around you yeah well I
had I had my own room thank God but not
everybody did did you masturbate I I'm
sure I did okay
um when I direct I was too too exhausted
to masturbate like it's the last thing I
could I always make time you make time
good for you
but when you're lying there how many
times out of this 22-day whatever shoot
would you close your eyes and go
this is this probably isn't going to
work I'm doomed my dreams are falling
apart to the best I can remember from 20
plus years ago I really
felt
like during that shoot it was just I was
enjoying it and having fun and I was
like it was exciting and I was working
on the daily challenges and I wasn't and
I and I was recognizing at the time how
lucky we were to be able to shoot this
thing and I wasn't thinking so much
about
whether there was no expectation that it
would even come out like I I was like if
we finish this movie and it gets a
review in the New York Times that's the
that's the goal that's all I wanted and
it never occurred to me
that it would be in the Consciousness 20
years later that was just not even on
the radar
you know I think you know when I when I
direct the movie I always you know you
want it to be successful you want it to
be whatever but I really at the end of
the day wanted my brother to laugh yeah
and I wanted the cast to really enjoy it
yeah and they did and I could tell at
the premiere the real laughs and that's
that meant everything to me this is what
I wanted to do this is what I could do
and I'm proud that I did that but you
knew you had something good on your
hands I think that we had the lucky
situation where Michael Showalter and I
took three years to get the financing to
make this movie and we kept rewriting it
and we kept we had this producer who was
Howard Bernstein was helping us out and
like we would just like keep diving back
in and even though it was you know on
the surface a dumb script we just really
kept honing it and we're like well this
no let's make this better let's make
this better so by the time we got to set
we really did have a very solid script I
think and that was everything that's
everything will there be any more wet
hot American Summers I doubt it I feel
like we sort of did the a very sort of
final ending to it at the end of the wet
hot 10 years later on Netflix 10 years
later and first day of camp yeah do you
uh ever go back to Ohio do you ever go
back for a reunion have you gone to a
Reunion yeah in Ohio where I grew up
yeah uh yeah I go well I go to home my
family's still there right and so I go
there you know once one to three times a
year are they uh very proud of you yeah
yeah and then did they get your humor do
they watch these things and go that's
really funny yeah it's funny I think a
lot of times though some people in my
family will enjoy it but on a different
level they're like oh that's so sweet or
that's so cute you know
and my parents were very my parents both
are uh passed away but they they both
were so their reactions to things were
so funny sometimes and just like like
well that I just really didn't get you
know and this one I hate and in fact I
hate oh yeah they're like this part in
fact we um I had my parents do with me
and Ken the commentary on our movie The
Ten because I just wanted the Cure there
like Blow by blow you know commentary on
the whole thing because they they were
that movie really pushes the envelope in
terms of tasteless things and and there
were things in there that they really
genuinely hated and I wanted to get that
on the record and what'd they say
they're like this one no I we I don't
know why you had to do this one David
you know just like did you love it oh I
loved it oh man
this is great um let me ask you this
what's the hardest moment you've had to
deal one of the hardest things you've
had to deal with in your life so far
career-wise or personal what when you
think of the first thing that comes to
you that this is the hardest thing I've
had to go through I
would say that the truth is no work
thing has ever been as hard as just
certain family relationship
things you know I've been through
marriage and divorce and uh you know
just different choices around
where to proceed there and moving to La
at a certain point and you know that's
sort of real life stuff has been
usually
you know I've had I've certainly had
work stresses and big problems or
choices and or and many many defeats
like many fail things that have yeah
Fallen apart at the last minute or jobs
that didn't come through in the last
minute or projects that I've worked
really hard on that failed you know many
most
um but I'm sort of used to that and the
fact I I look at it like
um
I still don't have to get a job uh
working behind the counter somewhere and
so that's the win
and everything else is a bonus and I try
to look at it like that do you do you
think you're more Fearless now after
dealing with rejection after dealing
with the ups and downs do you feel like
you were more Fearless when you were
just starting this business or do you
think over the years things have
happened which made you a little bit
more insecure
it's it's a very it sounds like I'm
invading the answer but it's both
I think that you know you're just life
changes you in different ways and
sometimes I feel
like I'm more in the zone and more like
sort of don't have to even try and
things happen and sometimes I feel like
it's things are more effortful and I and
I'm you know and obviously when if you
have four things in a row that fall
apart you feel less secure about what
you're doing right if you have four
things in a row that take off then you
feel more like you're Invincible it's
just natural do you always feel like uh
or do you feel I always think when I'm
deciding on a job or I get something you
know that I could potentially do I feel
like I don't want to let this person
down I don't want to let my age in town
I don't want to let this down yeah I
don't want it and I don't even think
about me most the time right what do you
[__] want yeah you should do that you
should think about it you shouldn't
think it certainly don't worry about
your agents and stuff well you know you
want to make them money they say this is
a great deal you keep saying no other
things they'll be okay they'll be fine
yeah they have other clients and also
don't worry about that it's just that's
not your job their job is to help you
thank you I think you're right who's the
who's the one person that you think of
when you're really at a low that you you
want to call and just hear their voice
and they'll make you feel better well I
mean my mom
and I can't do that ugh yeah was that
that was the hardest thing for you
wasn't it that was pretty tough how old
was she 74
was it unexpected no she was sick for a
few years
but so yeah it was it was like it was we
had the blessing of
being knowing she was going and being
able to be with her literally at that
time and
but it was you know there's I don't
think there's any scenario or time or
way to lose a parent that's okay
you know it's there's it's never like oh
that was did she lived a long life and
she died peacefully so everything so I'm
happy about it you know yeah it doesn't
matter I I envy you because I have a
feeling by talking about her how much
you loved I could tell by your emotion
but like
she knew how much you loved her and you
knew how much she loved you is that
right yeah
I think that that means a lot that's
very important to walk away with knowing
like there's no there's no way she
didn't know how much I freaking love
that one you know yeah
um you know yeah life and death is all
[__] up I I you know it's funny
because my uncle said something to me
while I was visiting my grandma who's 94
Blanche I also have a dog Blanche
um it's weird it's weird and he said
you know we were talking about death
and I'm not very close I love my mother
I love my Father Ryan that was a story I
I love them
and he said something he's like yeah I
don't know like we're talking about
death and like you know I'm I'm gonna be
responsible for taking care of the
funeral and taking care of this and you
know it's like all this and he's like
I think you should definitely see a
therapist
and talk to her or him about
losing your mother because I think
that's going to be really hard for you
and I go
what
we're not really close I don't talk to
her that much
because that's why and he's a
psychologist he's like I'm not trying to
beat Mr doctor here but I think that
it's going to hit you probably harder
than you thought and that scares me it
scares me that I'm not as close where I
could just
I love you Mom I love you so much I I
you know I don't you know and her I know
it's just it's just a different
relationship I do love her but every
yeah there's no I really do feel like
there's no
every situation is wildly different in
every way and so there's no template for
any of this and I have a very good
friend who just lost her mother and they
were not close at all and they had a lot
of tension over all all the years and
you know it's it's hard for her in a
very different way you know and it's but
it's
I don't know that I would have
recommended that she went and made
amends with her and tried to be close
with her again because that wasn't in
the cards for that relationship you know
so it just depends gotcha all right this
is called [__] talking with David Wayne
okay these are my top tier patrons
they get to ask questions go to
patreon.com inside of you these are top
joints
top tier patrons patreon patrons they
are okay and they're gonna ask questions
this is rapid fire or you could if you
feel like answering them long ways you
can okay uh Gianna H hi Gianna hi Jana
do you have any Stand Out memories from
the 10 one of my all time faves thank
you for mentioning the 10 Gianna
um this was a movie from
2007 uh and it was 10 different stories
each one inspired by one of the Ten
Commandments that it did with Ken Merino
uh and Paul Rudd uh and um
yeah oh it's uh many great memories
um getting to work with uh Winona Ryder
who was one of the weirder and greatest
uh actors I ever knew like she was so
awesome and very strange in all the best
ways
um we got to shoot four days of it in
Mexico in the in San Miguel de Allende
and it was like a very surreal
experience and working with a this
low-budget Mexican crew who just didn't
do anything that we asked but then did
all these other things that we didn't
ask for and it was just like a weird but
you know we would uh we would say oh
it's too bad there's all those like
antennas on the roofs of those buildings
and they're like okay and they just like
cut them all off oh my gosh
um or we had to do a scene where
somebody's Justin throws walking on
water and they like built this whole
scaffolding under the water without any
safety lay there was no concern for any
rules or anything but then I would be
like hey let's bring these decorations
on this day and they're like oh now the
guy just didn't come we're like well oh
we said it was gonna and he's like no
just been stuck in there no it's not
gonna happen and I was like oh but we
all said we're gonna start shooting at
10 they're like well you know 10 11 12
whatever you know and it's like anyway
it's very funny but
um
uh yeah it was the the 10 was a real
blast what's the weirdest thing Winona
Reiner did
[__] well she sometimes would just go we
would be uh literally about to roll like
okay you know
that lights camera action I'm about to
start and then she'd be like wait a
second and then take me off to the side
and talk about I'm not sure what
just like random random and I'm like oh
okay should we go back to the but she
was awesome we really is I mean she's
she another one who's just like that
camera rolls and you're like oh my God
she's so good yeah and was just lovely I
really you ever get Star Struck was she
was somebody who initially were a little
star yeah bye big time I don't get
Starstruck too often
um never did too much but you know
there's those certain people that you
have a real relationship with from your
own fandom in the past that you know you
meet them in
um but
uh you know
in fact it was interesting I just
recently worked with Steve Buscemi who
I've actually I've actually met him a
few times over the years and I've
uh you know and and so
but for whatever reason I was just like
so struck by him he was so cool and I
was just like excited to be in his midst
the whole time although I gotta be Mr
Pink for yeah that's it what a great
great actor you're a great you're a
great mimic thanks I didn't want to say
the next line I can't say it all right
you know the next line of that I
remember but I gotta be Mr Pink Floyd
Joe cause you're a
oh yeah yeah Leanne what challenge in
your life have you overcome that you're
extremely proud of
well as I said I learned the Rubik's
Cube finally there you go that's it
that's great yeah rapid fire Raj tell me
about an audition you felt went well did
but didn't work out how did you work
through that feeling of rejection
well as uh I'm not primarily an actor
right um but I have done quite a number
of auditions actually and there's been a
lot of times 19 of the time if I do an
audition I feel like that was pointless
I'd suck but sometimes I'm like oh my
God I am literally that guy there's no
it'd be crazy for them not to cast me
um and then they just don't and but I
know from having been on the other side
of it so many times that the reasons
could be anything you know it could be
that
there's there's no Rhyme or Reason to
why
ultimately why one person gets a job and
someone else does it and so you can
never take it personally have you ever
seen a big actor audition for you and
bomb yes just bomb yeah and they're a
great actor I mean we had
um
when we did the movie Wanderlust Judd
Apatow was the producer and there was
just a decision made that like everyone
had to audition even if they were big
names
um and so we had a lot of big names come
and sit and read our dumb script and it
was really sort of embarrassing in a way
to be like thank you sir for coming in
here like I don't know why you even have
to do this
um but you know some people are just not
that good at auditioning it has nothing
to do with their acting ability yeah
auditioning is not easy yeah it's a
whole different skill and so yeah I've
seen I've seen big people bomb but you
know I think auditioning is a very
sometimes necessary but very imperfect
way to to choose actors for something
would you rather just sit in a room with
somebody and talk to them knowing that
you've seen some of their work and you
know they're good and just have a
conversation will this person be good on
set will he be fun yeah do it I think
yes that has some value to it but I also
think that's also imperfect I think
better the best thing I I feel like
seeing people's work on screen is number
one like there should be much more
emphasis I think on reels and just like
and if they haven't done anything you
can make it real or make a self tape I
guess but I I it's
I just feel like um especially anyone
who's been around the block at all I
just have a lot of friends who are
actors who continually audition after
audition outages I'm like don't they
you've been on 40 things like I could do
this in my sleep like why do you have to
why do you ever have to audition again
like and it it breaks my heart that
they've worked so hard because
auditioning is hard you've got to do it
you know you don't want to put out a bad
one so yeah
last question little Lisa what is
something you have always wanted to do
but have not tried yet something purely
dramatic non-non directorially writing
directing whatever you want to do
something really dark something darker
just something that's not comedy first
it just I feel like it could you know
not that it's a crutch but I just I've
I've I love
uh dramatic
things and I and I've I just haven't had
the chance to do something that is not
relying on the comedy as the main engine
of it where could people follow you
what's your what's your handle David
Wayne w-a-i-n and it's the same handle
on Twitter Instagram
uh
Tick Tock I hope you invite me sometime
to play music in your garage you're so
invited I'm you're I'm dying for you to
come it's it looks like so much fun you
have these videos that are go to his
site go to his handle datawain.com also
davidwayne.com I mean just hilarious
you've got these great musicians and
these actors I mean really seeing songs
that we know and love yeah it's
basically me and my middle-aged dad
friends and you for example and we uh
and we just get together in the garage
and just play rock songs just for fun
um and then it's I've put a few clips of
it online but it's um truly it's one of
those things that's just fun thing for
friends to do and there's no goal around
it and there's no agenda the agenda
there's no reason but we're working hard
just because it's fun to put effort into
it um and make it sound as good as we
can but there's just it's leading to
nothing and that's part of the joy of it
do you have a big say in the music
that's in your movies
yeah well I've always been a musician as
a hobbyist or you know just interested
in music and so and I've worked very
closely with Craig wedron who's been the
composer on just about everything I've
done
um and yes I'm very very I'm very
Hands-On about all the aspects of the
movie and and the music is no exception
did you pick Jane for the hot American
series and not only did I think it was
one of the very first choices it was
from the movie originally and I I
remember
hearing that I was driving with my mom
in her car
sometime in the late 90s when I was
thinking about wet Hot American Summer
and what it would be and when that song
came on I was just like that has to be
the opening credits no matter what and
we were low budget movie and you know I
think we ended up putting an enormous
amount of our budget and just our
resources in making finding a way to get
that song and it was uh I love it so
much is it what would you say what hot
American is is the one that you
treasured dear to your heart is it
what's what's your favorite project that
you've done I know they're all close to
you they're all but the one that you're
like I had the most fun this is the most
rewarding this it's a really honestly
hard question because because they've
like yeah what how was the first movie
that I did with a real crew and it was
like so and obviously it has a very
special place in my heart and it was an
incredible experience in many ways and I
I often associate the project with the
experience of doing it less the final
thing
um so you know like the role model like
every they all have different wonderful
memories and different stresses that
come to mind and they were different
phases in my life you know in one I had
little tiny kids and in one I was going
through this in my relationship or in
this other one I was sad because of this
or happy because of that so those are
the associations in a way with the
projects but and then there are other
ones like
you know we did the show medical police
on uh Netflix which really just came and
went with a thud like nobody watched it
or cared about it and and that was
really sad for me like because I thought
it was awesome and as good as anything
else
um but and then there was things like
Children's Hospital which was like seven
year long beautiful job that got to do
every year and wonderful family of
people and you know so I I have been
teased by my friends for being a big fan
of all my own work but I am and good
last question this is it
what would you say to Young directors
trying to make it trying to make a name
for themselves what would you what
because somebody who really created
their own work I mean you created your
own success yeah what would you say to
them well it's it's so interesting
because my when I was younger trying to
figure it all out the world couldn't
have been more different in every
possible way YouTube didn't even exist
right you know there was no email
uh when I first started off and and so
um today and also the the tools of
production are available to anyone
so you can make you can actually make an
excellent looking feature film
yourself for 500 like and that that's
just insane from what from where I came
from you know and so uh as far as advice
I think that there's no substitute for
just doing the work of understanding how
to the the The Art of Storytelling and
learning English and history and
philosophy and you know things that I
still feel like I didn't do enough and
reading and there's nothing for actually
reading real books and
all of that if you do those things
you're going to be ahead of 90 of people
who are doing this stuff and then yeah
grab the camera and do your own thing
and put it up online and you know
there's no specific One path that I can
say is the way to get into it but
um
I would say just make sure if something
you care about do do something to move
you towards that goal every day this has
been awesome hasn't this been awesome
I I really just I I thought I was going
to be talking about your child and
talking about and it just it was so easy
to just talk to you about it and just
there's just [__] you're a great
interviewer thank you and this is I know
I hope this sounds like I'm saying this
is [__] but I think this is
literally the best podcast in the world
what as that sounds like I'm being I'm
exaggerating I haven't listened to it
yet but I'm going to
oh I really appreciate it I'm going to
listen to you thank you we could edit
that point I want to catch up we could
just take that little David thank you
for allowing me to be inside of you
today I always wish you the best I hope
to work with you someday thank you
brilliant we met do you remember where
we met
specifically no but I I remember uh many
nice experiences of hanging out with you
over the years the movie was called
1999. it was 1998 I believe when we made
it or 97 right right right and uh you
were always on the set I think you were
friends with the director Nick Davis
that's right and uh it was Jennifer
Garner can we can we talk about this for
a second sure keep it going for sure
because the the story of that is you
were in that movie I remember this now
and the
um I had never I was hoping to make wet
Hot American Summer but I had never been
on a feature film set in my life and I
was like how am I gonna do this and so I
my friend Nick was making a movie and I
said
that how I even knew him but I said oh
no I he wasn't my friend I
somehow I just
I went to film threat the magazine and
said I'm good can I do a story about the
behind the scenes of making this movie
for film threat but it was really just
an excuse for me to like hang out on a
film set
and I think that's how I met Nick Davis
I don't even know what my you know it's
funny I remember seeing you going you
look sort of like you know you're just
pensive and yeah and I go yes he's the
producer or something no I was I was
technically there as a reporter and
and I remember yeah and it was uh
fetterman
and and Amanda Pete and Jennifer Garner
Jennifer Garner and what's his name
um
Duo known as Steelers wheel when they
came up with this oh yeah Steven Wright
Steven Wright and uh Buck Henry Buck
Henry like what incredible cast graduate
meanwhile
uh and Timothy oliphon right this is my
buddy in that movie yeah what an amazing
group it was a group so then another it
wasn't the best movie I guess can I not
say that the problem was the
cinematography it just yeah it was a
little terrible yeah well it was very
low budget very low budget but I also
um the people who've made the who made
it were very nice and and I stayed in
touch with them a bit over the years and
then another actor who was in that movie
was Zandy hardig who I didn't really
meet on the set when I but I saw her
there and remember her from that but I
then met her like five years later and
married her
but you met her on the set of 1999 yeah
but I didn't remember that as well but I
remember her from the movie and I
remember I remember seeing her there but
I didn't actually meet her until like
late 2004
um and then I married her and had two
kids with her
and you remember seeing me
I do you do I do I have this long hair
and this leather jacket just so happy
and excited about being honest it was my
first feature so exciting I was like oh
my gosh this is great
Yeah Boy the time just flies since I was
a 90s it was for the 21st century it's
almost 25 years ago all right [__] that
all right see you man
[Laughter]
great guy a lot of fun and uh very
knowledgeable and uh we got deep we got
deep and uh it's always nice when people
open up as I always say and uh if you
enjoyed it again write a review tell me
what you think
follow the podcast follow our handles at
inside a podcast on the Facebook and
Instagram inside epod on the Twitter
I've got the inside of you online store
with tons of Smallville merch and I
inside of you merch and uh well again
we'll be in Chicago this weekend so
hopefully you'll be there hanging out
with us and um I'm gonna give the shout
outs uh top tiers of patreon patreon.com
we need you support the podcast if you
will I'll try to write you a message but
uh anything is great patreon.com
talkfill
and here we go all right Nancy D Leah
asks Sarah V little Lisa Yukiko I just
sent these people uh
things that are 20 off on inside of you
and tons of people uh said yes now I'm
gonna buy stuff 20 off that's good
so maybe I'll do some more of those
things
um Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason
W Sophie M Sophie M will get you that
Tuesday cup that glass I promise I just
got to remember Raj all good Rashi
thanks for the movie reviews uh Joshua D
Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal app Janelle B
Mike E Eldon Supremo 99 more Santiago M
Chad W Leanne P Janine R Maya P Maddie s
Belinda and Dave
and
H correct correct you got it Sheila G
Brad d Ray H tab of the T Tom and
Liliana a we got Talia
a tough one
c m Betsy D Chad l b or W Dan and Angel
and Rhiannon C Cory K Dev Nixon correct
Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy
uh Carlisle D that's right darlisle
Camille asks Joey M Eugene and Leah my
sweet Eugene and Leah we also have an
eye itch right now so I'm pausing for
station identification
uh Corey Heather L Jake B Megan T Angela
F Mel s Orlando C Caroline R Christine s
Eric H Shane r m r Andrew M zaroichi 77
Andreas and Oracle Karina n Amanda R gen
Jen B Kevin e Stephanie k j jorel jam
and J Leanne J Luna R Cindy e Mike F
Stone Age
Miss s Brian I Katie B
Aaron R Kendall L Kendall hi Kendall
house J what's up Meredith I what is
going on
Prof doctor scoots Professor Dr scoots
I'm assuming Charlene C kerosene Mary R
Kyle F Marisol p
I you know I think
no
yeah I think that's it
I think that's it is that all you have I
don't have a sheet how dare you oh it's
right here doing these names from memory
from memory from memory uh thanks so
much for listening to the podcast today
I hope you enjoyed it we got so many
great uh guests coming on and I think
what's nice is that the stuff I told you
Ryan that the podcast is getting more
established it's easier to get guests
um and it's Word of Mouth like Jonathan
Franks goes I love doing it and I go
could you get me Brent Spiner Gates
McFadden from Star Trek he's like yeah
and they're going to do the podcast and
uh you know
um
the the guy Ryan Kelly who was Ryan and
Smallville and and the show Ryan uh he's
his name's actually Ryan Kelly and uh he
was on Teen Wolf I believe he's gonna
come on he's got a big following and he
says he's going to do it so a lot of
great uh guests coming up I hope you'll
stick with the podcast join patreon and
uh
Ryan's still going to therapy still
going to therapy good yeah we all need
it yeah it's good I definitely need it
oh yeah
I was confused for a second because Ryan
Kelly is also the guy who taught me
trumpet I thought you were going to have
my trumpet teacher on but I guess you're
not really yeah you play trumpet could
you pick it up right now I could the
muscle memory would come back is a
trumpet more like
but yeah
I suppose you have to buzz your lips
that sounded like my butt that's how you
have to play trumpet thanks for
listening I'm Michael Rosenbaum from the
Hollywood Hills in California Bob Marley
that's correct a little wave to the
camera we love you guys couldn't do the
show without you I say it all the time
but I mean and you know I mean it so um
thanks for the support thanks for the
love and most importantly Ryan uh always
hold on to Smallville no that's an idea
what's the other one
uh be good to yourself be good to
yourself that's the most important thing
just be good to yourself
um if today you're like not happy with
yourself give yourself a break
tomorrow's a new day let's do it I'm not
preaching I'm just saying the facts
gotta love yourself I'm trying I'm
really trying all right we'll see you
next week
[Music]